así
el área en la que estoy posando es
nuestra aula de dibujo la llamamos gran
arte porque es un espacio realmente
grande aquí es donde los artistas
practican el dibujo de modelos en
diferentes poses los artistas buscan
dibujar no solo la forma del personaje
sino también las emociones que expresan
normalmente la pose solo se mantiene por
un minuto así que tienes que dibujar
rápida y libremente a este tipo de
dibujos lo conocemos como dibujo de
gestos y es una excelente forma de
capturar la idea detrás del dibujo sin
preocuparse por todos los detalles en él
espero que hayas disfrutado de lo
expresiva que podría ser tu lámpara con
tan sólo unos cuantos controles ahora
vamos a agregarle acción a la emoción
haremos que la lámpara salte piense en
lo que haces cuando saltas primero te
doblas y comprime hacia el suelo luego
saltas estirando t
estas son dos diferentes poses para
nuestra lámpara comprimir y estirar
entonces necesitamos agregar controles a
la lámpara para que pueda moverse a un
nuevo lugar podemos hacer esto al
agregar de formadores de rotación y
traslación a la base de la lámpara
algo que tenemos que considerar al
agregar de formadores es que algunos de
formadores necesitan operar en un orden
determinado esto podría ser un poco
difícil de imaginar así que permíteme
mostrarte
si rotamos antes de trasladar obtenemos
un efecto diferente que si trasladamos y
luego rotamos observa que podemos
determinar el orden de estos de
formadores haciendo clic y arrastrando
así y el orden en el que operan fluye en
este sentido los animadores que usan
estos se mueven a una posición y luego
usan rotaciones se mueven a otra
posición y usan rotaciones de nuevo y
así sucesivamente por ello deben poder
girar objetos sobre la base sin importar
donde los trasladen pero si nuestros de
formadores operan en el orden equivocado
trasladar y rotar nos enfrentaremos con
un problema la rotación de la lámpara se
alejará de la pose así eso es porque
movimos la lámpara lejos del eje de
rotación que es la posición inicial de
la base
podemos resolver este problema haciendo
que nuestros de formadores operen en el
orden opuesto primero rotamos sobre el
origen de la base y luego movemos la
base esta dependencia sobre el orden se
conoce como no conmutativa actividad
bueno puedes aprender más acerca de esto
en la elección de escenarios y montajes
en el ejercicio siguiente nuestro
objetivo es mover nuestra lámpara a su
lugar y luego hacerla que pose mediante
rotaciones así que tendrás que prestar
atención al orden de tus deformadores de
traslación y rotación que te diviertas